supongamos que decidimos ir a practicar
canotaje y esta es una vista desde
arriba del río
este es nuestro río y supongamos que la
corriente va hacia la derecha así que
hay dos direcciones diferentes en las
que podemos usar la canoa aquí vamos a
imaginar que alguien va en la misma
dirección de la corriente se mueve hacia
allá pero también vamos a imaginar que
otra persona va en su canoa en sentido
contrario aquí tenemos a alguien en su
canoa que va río arriba entonces esta
persona barrio abajo y esta persona
barrio arriba va en esta dirección
pausa en el vídeo y piensen en qué
persona necesitará gastar más energía o
dicho de otra manera qué persona estará
más activa y qué persona estará más
pasiva bueno no fue una pregunta muy
difícil si vamos en el mismo sentido de
la corriente como la persona en amarillo
ni siquiera necesitamos sacar los remos
simplemente tomamos
una siesta y la canoa naturalmente se
moverá con la corriente así que esta
persona es pasiva se mueve pasivamente
mientras que la persona en azul tendrá
que trabajar mucho remará para no irse
hacia la derecha y luego remar a todavía
más para ir en contra de la corriente
así que esta persona tendrá que estar
muy activa bueno esta es solamente una
metáfora para hablar sobre la idea en
biología de transporte activo contra el
transporte pasivo empecemos con el más
agradable empecemos con el transporte
pasivo el transporte pasivo es cuando
algo va junto con el gradiente que
quiero decir con eso bueno supongamos
que aquí tenemos un tubo y vamos a
suponer que está lleno de agua y de este
lado del tubo tenemos una concentración
alta de alguna molécula disuelta en agua
mientras que del lado derecho tenemos
una concentración baja entonces que
creen que pasará
estas moléculas se moverán naturalmente
y con el tiempo muchas de estas
moléculas se moverán pasivamente hacia
la derecha y se distribuirán hasta que
en algún punto tendremos una
concentración igual o aproximadamente
igual en todo el contenedor por lo tanto
a este movimiento a lo largo del
gradiente de concentración que en este
caso va de una concentración alta a una
baja se le conoce como transporte pasivo
y bueno a esto se le llama gradiente de
concentración porque las moléculas se
mueven de un lado al otro del contenedor
vamos a escribir este es un gradiente
de concentración pero también podríamos
tener un gradiente eléctrico dibujemos
nuevamente el contenedor supongamos que
también está lleno de agua y ahora
imaginen que del lado izquierdo tenemos
un montón de partículas o moléculas
positivas mientras que del lado derecho
tenemos un montón de partículas o
moléculas negativas ok entonces las
partículas son moléculas positivas se
repelen entre ellas al igual que las
negativas pero las positivas atraen a
las negativas y las negativas atraen a
las positivas así que podemos pensar en
que las cosas se mueven naturalmente
debido a su gran ente eléctrico las
cargas positivas se quieren alejar entre
ellas y son atraídas a las negativas e
igualmente las cargas negativas se
quieren alejar entre ellas y son
atraídas a las positivas
ya hablamos del gradiente de
concentración o gradiente eléctrico pero
muchas veces podemos tener una
combinación de los dos y a eso se le
conoce como gradiente electroquímico y
si al movernos a lo largo del gradiente
no tenemos que usar energía a eso se le
conoce como transporte pasivo aquí no se
necesita no se necesita energía ocurrirá
naturalmente ahora el caso contrario es
el transporte activo transporte activo y
aquí es cuando algo se mueve en
dirección contraria al gradiente por
ejemplo supongamos que nos encontramos
en esta situación y en lugar de que una
de estas partículas o moléculas se mueva
en esa dirección va en sentido contrario
al gradiente se mueve en esa dirección
otra situación sería que si tenemos una
partícula positiva aquí en lugar de
moverse naturalmente en esta dirección
por alguna razón se mueve en sentido
contrario
a su gradiente y se acerca más a las
otras partículas positivas entonces este
tipo de transporte necesita energía para
realizarse y probablemente el ejemplo
más común de transporte activo que
veremos en una clase de biología es la
famosa bomba de sodio potasio que
estudiaremos a detalle en otros vídeos
vamos a ver supongamos que aquí tenemos
una membrana celular y estoy dibujando
la así por una razón y afuera de la
membrana celular tenemos algunos iones
de potasio pero tenemos más en el
interior todos estos son iones de
potasio que se encuentran en el interior
de la célula aquí tenemos camas camas y
camas y después tenemos algunos iones de
sodio en el interior de la célula enea
más pero tenemos más en el exterior el
exterior de la célula tiene más iones
positivos que el interior
tal vez sea vieron hacia dónde vamos con
todo esto tiene a más n a más n a más ok
ahora sí en esta parte de la membrana
tenemos un canal que estaba abierto
únicamente para el potasio solamente el
potasio puede pasar a través de este
canal que creen que pasará bueno aquí
tenemos un transporte pasivo porque
estos potasio cargados positivamente van
hacia abajo por el gradiente de
concentración y es más probable que un
ión de potasio golpe aquí de forma
adecuada para pasar por este canal
porque hay más potasio en la parte
interna de la célula que en la parte
externa entonces este potasio va desde
una concentración baja a una
concentración alta a través de este
canal aquí tenemos un transporte pasivo
pero imaginemos que aquí también hay un
transporte activo y el transporte activo
es lo que bombea los iones de sodio que
se encuentran en el interior de la
célula hacia
el exterior incluso aunque vaya en
contra de su gradiente de concentración
y en contra del gradiente eléctrico como
el exterior es más positivo no
pensaríamos que unión positivo se
movería naturalmente al exterior porque
en el exterior hay más iones de sodio
que en el interior pero en la bomba de
sodio potasio los odios son llevados al
exterior de la célula y para eso se
necesita energía es por eso que muchas
veces se encontrarán un diagrama de la
bomba sodio potasio dibujado así no voy
a profundizar mucho porque tenemos otro
vídeo dedicado completamente a esto pero
la idea general es que los odios se unen
aquí y después el atp que es la central
eléctrica de las células que también
estudiaremos más adelante en biología el
atp nos sirve como una palanca de
energía que cambia la forma de las
proteínas que construyen esa bomba de
sodio potasio para impulsar a los odios
hacia afuera de la célula
salen de la célula y bueno las enzimas
reales se ven un poco diferentes pero
esa es la idea general usamos energía en
forma de atp para sacar los iones de
sodio al exterior de la célula a pesar
de que van en contra del gradiente de
concentración y de su gradiente
eléctrico por eso se conoce como
transporte activo hemos terminado nos
vemos en otro vídeo